so next game against Marzipan Cat oh
come on let's do
something funny here
I know a little bit about it as a
black worm
yes a position that I looked at as a black
worm is definitely
pretty crazy
so
so damn here I played there once
and then I should  supposedly there's more one thing that's
somehow
interesting, crazy,
well let's see,
he takes it away too, yes I did that back
then too, so
now I think he has to swap the queen,
only he can't. Knight
G6 threatens, yes, and there Knight F3 or something like that  For
example, if he now plays G3 or
or knight goes 3 or something like that
he actually has to swap now
so at most we have
seven here maybe
swapped
like that and at that time I was still in the board
I should get into trouble
but I really can't do it
anymore  remember what it was
like, well maybe just
develop it or something like that or to
get the F4 back
I have to count for a moment here I
specified an installation
okay but now I can also take G4
G4
I take F4 knight bishop F6
well I
can do that  Just hit G4
or not, it
's also rare that you can then give
check,
so
at least now he can't
even play knight 7 or something like that because
he can't take the four either, I
think spoon H6, it looks pretty
dangerous, I
don't think I'm threatening  here G4 with the
idea Bishop H6
Bishop H6
can still pretend G8 of course
play so
Desperado moderately
but okay comes that just looks
like it's somehow right
or
not on knight the four also
some other move
King F2 or something like that  It's very easy to play, just go
back again
so now
no I have to take it first
Queen which is always Bishop H6 now
in the next move
or on this I thought Bishop G5
yes this bishop still covers
this one
so so so
now I thought this and  then
knight F6
you can never take it
actually
so
time warning wow
what an amazing position
the six
wow yes
always funny the king
maybe not that great but definitely
always interesting